okay you'll remember it was exactly a
week ago that police here finished their
three-day search of the Arad Reservoir
which was an area believed to have been
frequently visited by the prime suspect
in The Disappearance of Madeleine McCann
in 2007. that's the convicted sex
offender Christian B who's currently in
prison in Germany and we've just had an
updated statement from the German
prosecutor you'll remember it was the
German prosecutor who asked for those
searches to be carried out with the
cooperation of the Portuguese
authorities now in this statement
they've said that the search carried out
last week on that area ended after three
days as was planned they've said a
number of items were seized as part of
the operation and in the coming days and
weeks those items will be evaluated they
said it's not yet possible to say
whether some of the items are actually
related to the Madeleine McCann case
they've gone on to thank the police
forces that are involved in this but
have also noted the investigations
conducted here in Germany against the 46
year old suspect which is Christian B
are expected to continue for some time
so clearly I think what the German
prosecutor is doing here is showing
their workings there's a huge amount of
global interest in this case they're
updating saying tests are still going on
but also more importantly that Christian
B is still being investigated